spoke with drew brees earlier this
morning and when he showed up about nine
minutes late and I opened up the
question to do drew brees by asking him
when was the last time you were late for
a meeting
[Laughter]
it's probably been a while just probably
been a while why do you ask
I don't know you sound guilty I am
guilty I was nine minutes wait I was
nine minutes late on you I'm sorry no
worries no worries I mean I'm in
midseason form already you're just in
training camp so it's not yeah forgive
me but you wouldn't get fined if you
showed up late for a meeting would you
no I absolutely would everybody's
treated the same around here Zion comes
to town and all of a sudden it's a
pretty big deal and then he comes over
to you know camp with you guys that was
pretty big buzz it felt like do you
think you got a spot on the roster for
Zion he's uh he's a big guy he can he
could definitely help us uh as a red
zone threat and if we if we really
wanted to um you know just just a couple
plays a game just jump up first bait
balls or you know maybe the back line of
the endzone or something like that
yeah he's a he's a great athlete
obviously everybody's really excited to
have oil and some I think we've kind of
in a position with the pelicans now we
can really build build a solid
foundation for the future not just him
but Jackson Hayes we got I think with
the 8th pick and and obviously that that
big trade with the Lakers and getting a
bunch of other talent but we got a great
great guard and drew holiday as well so
I think everybody's pretty pumped about
the pelicans this year yeah I could see
the competitor and you when you're
shooting you know here's ion you welcome
him over as a guest and then you wanted
you know what you want to beat him in
that shooting contest I can tell when
you started to gear up a little bit that
you had to crank it up there's that I
had to show the young fella that you
know back in the day I played a little
too
you know and so I well I well I don't
quite have the outside shot that maybe I
used to I can I can still I could still
throw it down every now as soon as they
that you guys started the shooting
contest I said to my guys I said Drew's
gonna win this I said he's a better
shooter than Zion and he you're far more
competitive than Zion is Zion didn't
know you were probably going to be that
competitive yeah I I think maybe I just
kind of lured him in you know and in
deep down you know I'm kind of sneaking
into the pelicans building after
practice and getting some getting some
practice I like it that's pretty much
how that went down you didn't play
tackle football till high school right
correct what about your your three boys
what's what what did you and Mom decide
on that
well it's if they do want to pursue it
then we'll probably wait till middle
school at least so until then I'll play
flag football they're playing lacrosse
they're playing basketball they're
playing a little tennis they're playing
a little bit everything I think that's
the best thing you can do for kids just
expose them to as many sports as
possible let them develop the skill set
with all of them and then at some point
if they ever want to you know pursue a
specific one and you start to specialize
make sure that's not until middle school
or beyond because the more sports they
can play right now the better it is for
their overall development a Kurt Warner
a couple years ago told me that he I
don't know if discouraged his kids are
wanted to to not play football he'd
prefer they didn't play football you
know you're following a hall-of-famer
and plus the sport itself does that
factor in at all yeah I think it's more
I think it's more maybe just the
pressure and the expectation level that
would come along with it but I'd say at
this point I don't I don't think any of
my kids are gonna play quarterback
necessarily so maybe that takes the
pressure off a bit I just I love what
sports do for kids just in general I
think it's I think it's a great outlet I
think it's a great way to develop
overall skill development overall
athleticism and the life skills you
learn from sports team sports especially
I mean that's I was a sports junkie as a
kid and that's all I wanted to do and so
I'm not just going to assume that my
kids are going to be that way so I sit
back and I just allow them to you know
pursue and show interest in what they
want to do and as soon as they do then I
jump in and I try to help them cultivate
that but no pressure for me as far as
playing sports or not although I do
think it's one of the best things that
kids can do talking to the Saints
quarterback Drew Brees how often does
your age come up like daily basis no you
know I almost feel like it was coming up
more last year and maybe as you're
approaching the 40 mark you know that's
that's when people talk about it more
and more and then once once you once
your birthday comes and goes then
everybody quits talking about it I find
that that's kind of been the case but do
you think Brady made it irrelevant I
think we don't it used to be you know if
you got over 35 you were old in that
sport at that position now all of a
sudden Brady blows through that wins the
Super Bowl and we're not questioning age
as much as maybe what we once did yeah
maybe maybe the ceilings being lifted a
little bit right I think so I mean you
look at Ben you look at rivers you
Rodgers is gonna get there the
conditioning the eating taking care of
you some braids he says he's bulking up
this year to take more hits all right
have you ever done that well it's funny
because I was I was 221 in college
usually that much yeah 221 6-foot 221
but we're big can and we were running I
was actually running the ball a little
bit so I felt like I kind of needed that
plus it was the college weight program
right yeah and I feel like as I've
gotten older I've I've leaned out I'm
not at the point where it's hard for me
to keep on weight I mean I eat anything
and everything in sight to keep my
weight but
you know I'm I'm 202-204 but I feel I
feel athletic I feel like I can move I
feel like I've got you know quick twitch
so it's it's one of those where I think
you just kind of find your balance and
maybe at different stages of your career
you just kind of hit different you know
benchmarks as far as you know what you
weigh and and how that makes you feel
and I feel like maybe it was maybe it
was Shannon Sharpe or even Tony Gonzalez
that you know as they got later in their
careers now obviously they're playing
you know the tight in position where you
know they got to have some bulk in order
to you know block and do different
things that you're asking the tight in
position to do but from from a receiving
perspective I feel like those guys kept
just getting a little bit lighter each
year and it was almost just so it was
less less stress on their joints just
the ability to still play play fast and
be productive you know your longest run
from scrimmage in the NFL yeah mm-hmm 21
yards 22 that was back with the Chargers
really yeah I am I had one about four or
five years ago in the dome it was about
45 yards but I think there's a holding
call I'm going with that one wait wait
but if there isn't a holding call truth
in it you don't run for 45 yards you
know how that works right how do you how
do you know that there's holding on
every play in the NFL drew right did you
follow the NFL top 100 list there I
I followed a little bit of it if it was
if it was on and I caught it in the
background I caught what Allen chimera
being 14 Mike Thomas being 13 and you
know where you are
well I was just told that this morning
yes number two overall
are you are you happy with that or does
it bother you well all I know is this I
I wholeheartedly agree with who got
number one
Peron Donald do you think he's the best
player in football there's no question
there's no question Wow unbelievable
who's the second best player in football
I don't know it might be you Dan if I
was in the NFL oh but all you know all
kidding aside second best player in
football skill and it's okay to say you
met well how do you how do you not put
the guy with six people in there number
two they didn't why I didn't I didn't
understand that look here's the thing
while I while I appreciate well I
appreciate the the voting that put me at
number two I think if you're if you're
even getting in the top ten how do you
differentiate who's who's in front of
who at that stage right you could
probably validate any of those guys in
the top ten as being number two or
number three or number four so I think
that's probably just a group it's also
not that area yeah and trying to figure
out quarterback like what is your
measuring stick for greatness is is like
this is how we grade quarterbacks like
this is where your ranking should be it
should be based on what
I don't think it's as simple as saying
it's it's one thing or another
I mean first you'd say is that there's
the guy win right is the guy win does a
guy win on a consistent basis is it a
consistent level of play consistent
level of productivity all those things
factor on yeah because I you know we get
into these arguments where somebody says
oh Aaron Rodgers is overrated
and then I'll go okay he's over what
does that mean he's overrated or
somebody's underrated and and then you
go greatest quarterback of all time and
then well it's got to be Brady and then
it's Montana and I go I don't even know
how to differentiate who's great when
they're great how much the team their
defend like it's it's kind of hard but
that's how we rank quarterbacks is how
many championships you have whether
that's fair or not listen it's all I
know is to have six of them is is it's
pretty unbelievable
are you going to call Brady and
apologize for being ranked second on the
NFL no you know it's funny I mean I'm I
have such a great appreciation for for
this game and and for the guys who have
played the quarterback position for a
long period of time in this game too and
so as I as I look to I mean I think each
era I think each generation it kind of
has its its greatest quarterbacks of all
time
because each each era each generation I
think I think kind of I think it stands
alone because of maybe the circumstances
at the time and the rules at the time or
what have you you know I like the
numbers that that guys put up now
compared to 20 years ago or 30 years ago
like it's not even close right yeah but
it doesn't mean that the guys now are
better than the guys were then it's just
that's the way the game was played then
versus now right there's things those
guys had to deal with that we don't have
to deal with right there there's rules
that are anymore
favor now than they were then but
there's more complexity with defense now
than there was that and so you could go
back and forth on you know which era is
better and why but at the end of the day
I think they just all stand alone and I
think we should sit back and we should
appreciate like what guys like Otto
Graham were able to accomplish right or
guys like you know Fran Tarkenton or
Terry Bradshaw and then on into Joe
Montana and Elway and Marino and you
know all these guys the you know Bart
Starr back back in the 60s you know and
so it's it's it's just I think each
generation stands alone and we should
sit back and really appreciate what all
those guys accomplished during their era
by the way I picked you guys go to the
Super Bowl last year and I know we have
to get past that bad call
I don't know how you're getting past it
but I'm not past it yet just to let you
know is there anything you can do about
it
you guys win this year there any way
that Dan is there anything with Dan
Patrick can do that so that right now I
am willing to testify in that lawsuit
that apparently that fan has like should
we put should we put you on the
competition committee oh okay there's no
18 games by the way there's no 18-game
schedule maybe 17 and an extra wild card
or so but that's it okay if I'm on the
competition committee yes if you're
trying to increase regular-season games
you're off okay all right well then no
17 games 16 we stay and we add maybe
another playoff vodka how's that all
right you're getting warmer you're
getting warmer okay you're still in all
right but let's move past that call okay
let's never forget it but let's move
past it yeah yeah it's uh as as
listening that took a long time to get
over you know you'll never get over it
drew you totally get over it now yeah do
you totally get over it no but man I I
feel like I was taught a long time ago
that if you if you sit there and worry
about the things you can't control
then you're gonna drive yourself
absolutely nuts so I know that there
were things that happen throughout the
course of that game that we that were in
our control that would have changed the
outcome and so that's what I'm those are
the things I'm focused on
I like our team I love our team and
we've got all the pieces in place to
make a run at it and you got to prove it
each and every week in this league and
that's what's so great about our game
that's why we love it that's why you
love it that's why the fans love it is
it each and every week you have to show
up and there's nothing that's given man
you got to earn everything I like it all
right I feel a little bit better hey
great to talk to you as always and we'll
catch up during the season sounds good
you still got my vote for competitions
many thank you for me but thank you I'll
take that thank you drew all right there
for more Dan Patrick show tune in the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on BR Live or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]